par toute une série d'innovations le
président de la république monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing a voulu
redonner cette année au 14 juillet un
caractère de grande fête populaire et
lui conserver son aspect historique
c'est pour cette raison que ce défilé a
été transporté des champs elysées à la
bastille lieu le plus symbolique de la
révolution française et vers des
quartiers plus habités afin que le
maximum de parisiens puissent en
profiter
c'est par un décret de 1880 que la fête
nationale a été fixée en france au 14
juillet il faut remonter à 1945 pour
voir la fête nationale
exceptionnellement marquée par un grand
défilé militaire entre la bastille et la
république sur le même itinéraire que
celui choisi par le président de
république 1974 que pensent les
parisiens de ce nouveau défilé
ça c'est une bastille qui n'est pas la
même
parce que la véritable bastille et ben
c'était celle que j'avais dans mon coeur
celle là je vais vous dire un truc elle
est transformée en western que je serai
contente parce que la partie ça tue
toujours à nos jours moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord tu veux te 14 juillet à la
bastille
c'est tous les ans pour beaucoup mais
enfin j'ai l'impression que
ils auront beaucoup moins de place aux
gens de les indemniser
sans se désister pour les étrangers la
menace peut pas me déranger alors comme
je vois la télévision dans l'ensemble
c'est une idée comme une autre enfant
les blindés habits mettre toutes les
rues de paris avec je dis que c'est une
économie réfection carburant à de
carburant il ya il va y aura les avions
qui volent et le froid qui pullulent pas
autant qu'un temps quand un avion alors
faux gentil qui vont faire l'économie
qui mieux mieux les cas là dessus que
pour le chauffage
dans les maisons l'hiver ou même pour
les véhicules
oui évidemment je ne vois pas traduire
mouse qu'il faudrait des blindés moi mon
avis il va y avoir certainement des
embouteillages monstres la cérémonie
commencera à 9h 15 lorsque le président
la république accompagné du premier
ministre du ministre défense nationale
arrivera sur le quai de montebello afin
de passer les faux porn 9h25 monsieur
giscard d'estaing déposera une gerbe au
pied de la colonne de juillet avant de
prendre place sur la tribune officielle
composée uniquement de troubles à pied
ce défilé rassemblera treize mille
hommes qui marcheront derrière 38
drapeau ou éteint
quant au défilé aérien il commencera à
9h30
à noter enfin qu arriver place de
république les troupeaux gagneront leur
véhicule par la rue de turbigo le
boulevard saint-martin et magenta
pour la première fois depuis de
nombreuses années les pompiers de paris
ne défileront pas à bord de leurs engins
d'un saute créé par napoléon 1er en 1811
le corps des sapeurs pompiers de paris
et depuis le 1er mars 1967
érigé en brigade cette prestigieuse
unité forme encore appartient à l'arme
du génie et son commandement est assuré
par général fait rouge qui vient d'être
promu au rang de commandeur dans l'ordre
de la légion d'honneur
cette brigade a pour principale mission
d'assurer en toutes circonstances la
protection et la sécurité des personnes
contre l'incendié ainsi que les périls
des accidents de toute nature les 133
communes y compris paris où s'exerce sa
compétence regroupe une population
supérieure à 6 millions cinq cent mille
habitants
articulée en 78 centres de secours cette
unité dispose de six milles 320 gradés
et sapeurs et de me lever pour l'année
1973 le bilan opérationnel de la brigade
fut de 80 mille cinq cents interventions
dont plus de 5000 asphyxie et plus de
12000 incendie 2 102 sapeurs pompiers
furent blessés au cours de
l'intervention
cette année encore vous pourrez
applaudir les détachements du personnel
féminin désormais de terre de mer et de
l'air en ce qui concerne les pépins
sachez qu'ils assurent principalement
des fonctions de convoyeuse de l'air à
bord d'avions de transport militaire le
personnel navigant occupant des postes
de rédactrice interprète opératrice en
transmission ou encore secrétaire
dactylo ce qui bien sûr n'a rien à voir
avec les nippes hot chip
parmi les hommes d'élite nous
retiendrons cette année la présence du
1er régiment de chasseurs parachutistes
de passionnés ap le 1er rcp qui
n'appartient l'armée de terre que depuis
1945 a pris part ou campagne d'italie de
france et d'indochine son drapeau porte
la croix de guerre 39 45 avec deux
palmes et celle des théâtres
d'opérations extérieures avec cette pâle
derrière le 1er rcp vous pourrez admirer
le 8e régiment de parachutistes
d'infanterie de marine qui avec ses 24
années d'existence et ses 14 années de
campagne et le régiment des
parachutistes engagés français
voici maintenant le 13e bataillon de
chasseurs alpins coiffé de la célèbre
tarte est en 1853 besançon le 13e bca
participa aux opérations de kabylie et
du maroc puis de la guerre de 1870 où il
s'illustra afro cheminait reybaz est
engagé dans la première guerre mondiale
il se distingua sur tous les fronts de
la belgique à la champagne de la somme à
l'italie en passant par la picardie le
chemin des dames les vosges et l'alsace
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale il
est envoyé en norvège et dans la somme
dissous en 1942 il se disperse dans les
maquis de savoie plus combat dans les
halles où il s'illustre notamment au
combat du col du petit saint bernard à
partir de 1945 il séjourne dans le tyrol
autrichien en 1953 bien chambéry où il
forme juste en 1962 des combattants pour
l'afrique du nord aujourd'hui le 13e bca
et fier d'être titulaire de neuf
citations à l'ordre de l'armée et la
croix de guerre norvégien
oui c'est bien la légion étrangère qui
clôturera ce défilé du 14 juillet 1974
dans l'articulation suivante emblème et
chef de corps du 1er régiment étranger
la musique de la légion une section de
pionnier un escadron du 1er régiment
étranger de cavalerie compagnie du 2e
régiment étranger une compagnie du 2e
régiment étranger de parachutistes au
son du boudin la musique de la légion
qui se compose de son exécutant défilera
comme à l'habitude à la cadence de 90
pas mieux avec leurs barbes leur tablier
depuis orange et leur âge sur l'épaule
et pionnier perpétueront le respect des
traditions et la ford région aidera
ensuite le premier en garnison à orange
il participa aux campagnes du maroc et
de syrie vise la campagne de france au
débarquement en provence à la libération
des projets de l'alsace et aux
opérations d'indochine et de l'algérie
compte étendard du premier acte est
décoré de 2,3 pierre et sipa ou le 2e
rei est l'héritier d'un passé lourd de
gloire acquise au long de 127 années
d'existence formé en 1841 il parcourt
quatre continents et inscrit 18 bataille
sous les 60 brabo proclamé libérateur
l'italie il est second dans l'ordre des
combats accompli dans les régimes
étrange le deuxième rêve hérité du 2e
bataillon étranger de parachutistes
largués sur le camp retranché de dien
bien phu
puis participe aux opérations de
maintien de l'ordre en algérie en
garnison à calvi il appartient à la 2e
brigade aéroportée dans les rangs de
laquelle il est intervenu au tchad
devant de tels faits d'armes
une chose reste certaine on ne parlera
jamais assez de la légion étrangère et
des hommes qui la servent